there's nobody who's writing me a check
for the idea
of liquid death they're like you're this
is stupid you're crazy like
we launched liquid death in a bit of a
backwards way than most i think beverage
brands launch
which was we launched a year before we
met science
we launched liquid death on social media
before we ever had product
because we knew that with such a crazy
idea like liquid death
there's nobody who's writing me a check
for the idea of liquid death they're
like you're this is stupid you're crazy
like
who would ever buy this it's a negative
name it says death retailers will never
carry it yadda yadda
so i knew that i had to prove it out as
a concept on social first
before i could actually make people feel
like i'm de-risking
this thing a bit to actually raise so
we designed the can to look like a 3d
realistic can
we shot a 1500 video
and then we just put it on facebook no
twitter
no instagram just facebook we put maybe
um
i don't know three grand in paid media
behind the video
and then cut to three months later we
have more
facebook followers than aquafina the
video has three million views
we've got a range of dms from hi
i am a 7-eleven franchisee in the
midwest how do i get this in my stores
or hi i'm the biggest non-out beverage
distributor in new york city called big
geyser
how do we talk to a sales representative
to distribute this
and we didn't even have product yet
right no idea of how we were even going
to really make it
so then i use all that social traction
and
distributor interest and retailer
interest to then start raising a small
friends and family round so we can
actually produce physical product
because with cans
the minimums are really really high like
quarter million cans is the
lowest you can actually produce with a
can manufacturer so it's a little bit
capital intensive just to even
start playing the game how much does a
quarter million how much
a quarter of a million a product what
would that cost i mean if you're just
starting with that cost
i mean it all depends what you're
feeling in there but i mean
i mean yeah i mean you're you're talking
you know 150 200 250 grand just to like
kind of get started probably
you know doing cans um
so yeah once we once we then kind of
raised a little bit we started producing
cans
we we bottle oh well we can and source
our water in austria
in the alps um once we had physical
cans the people what does that mean
whenever people are like oh this is you
know spring water from this mountain
it's like
you know my head is always like this is
bs what does this mean does that mat
like a is this true
b does that matter um so like why do you
go get your water from austria
in the alps like what is that is that is
that branding
is that like is there something about
water that i don't know like why do you
have to go there to get your water
so what i mean let's be totally honest
water for the most point part i should
say for most people is water
yeah like if you had people try to even
even water snobs
if you had them blind taste test fiji
versus evian versus whatever can they
really tell the difference
probably not right but i've done this
test
many times as an avion drinker epione
versus
so evian and fiji are tastes similar to
me evian versus
crystal geisler like it tastes different
i've
i've bet money and i've got it right
before that's interesting
but yeah i think the things that make
water
that affect the taste of water are
the natural minerals and how much of
them there are in the water
and the ph of the water is it more
acidic
is it more basic and what those minerals
are affect
how acidic or how basic it is so
when you for us our water comes from the
alps
and it literally goes right from the
mountain into the can
obviously it goes through filters and
things that filter out debris and all
that
and then we put it through like a
pasteurization process that makes sure
everything you know it's all clean and
good to go
but everything in that water is
that's the natural mineral profile of
the water that has been built up over
probably hundreds of years in the
mountain
and it's like you know naturally
alkaline at 7.8 or 7.9 ph it's got a
nice mineral level
nice mouth feel when you're drinking it
because of the level of minerals
so that comes right off that way it's
all everything's natural about it
almost every major water brand in the
u.s
whether that's smart water essentia
aquafina dasani
most of those brands they're using
you just tap from the that then they
reverse
osmosis which strips everything out of
water all the natural minerals
all the bad stuff everything so it's
literally just like
empty water then they have to
add in minerals back in to kind of make
it taste good so they'll add in
the natural things that occur in water
but just kind of artificially with just
doing it at the factory to kind of make
something that has a decent ph
and a decent mineral profile that tastes
good so
those are kind of the two options when
you say something is spring water
it's very strict from the fda of what
that has to be
like to call it spring water you cannot
alter the original mineral
profile of the water so even if you take
it off the mountain
if you put it through reverse osmosis
and it strips out the natural minerals
and you add them back in you can't call
it spring water anymore because you've
altered the original
thing so you know
our water like i said that that's kind
of how we think about it
um everything we have in our water is
natural that's how it comes off the
mountain
it's kind of its own perfect thing we
don't have to go through the whole
process of like
using municipal tap water from the
factory
stripping everything out adding stuff in
and kind of like
creating a water right now that that's
great okay
and you know i've never actually had
liquid death um
it's flat water though right it's not
sparkling and it's not flavored we have
a sparkling
version but we have a still and a
sparkling yeah and
um and so you uh sorry just to sort of
finish it so you you took that you know
you raised a little bit you did the
social media to prove hey we can build a
fun brand that people resonate with
then you figured out okay to produce the
minimum run i'm gonna need a couple
hundred grand
to get this thing off the ground and you
raise kind of the friends and family
round
uh that was from science or afterwards
science came about and they wrote a
bigger check
we raised the friends and family round
just to basically cover like a super
limited
you know the smallest run of product we
could do right
and then once i finally had a physical
can of liquid that for the first time
which was probably around october
of 2018.
we had a a guy that we knew who knew
someone at science who said hey you guys
should really talk to science like
they'd probably be all over this
so we went and met with science and
brought down the physical can
and once someone could really hold it
and it wasn't just like us showing
digital images from social it made it
way different
it just like they understood the magic
of it and how cool this would be
walking around with this or how you know
how into this people would be so then we
that's when we kind of decided to do a
deal with science
and over the next two months after that
they helped us gear up our d2c launch
where we launched online in january of
last year